[Music]
throughout 2018 cero proved himself to
be the most dominant force in
competitive Starcraft in addition to
becoming the only player to have ever
won every single WCS circuit event in
one year Sara also became the 2018
Starcraft 2 world champion by winning
Blizzcon the game is most prestigious
tournament
but the thing that's most incredible
about Cyril's feet is that he achieved
it as a non-korean for nearly two
decades
South Korea's had a monopoly over
competitive Starcraft from the PC bonds
in which they played it to the bonds was
who mastered it Starcraft has long been
South Korea's obsession and they
dominated it in becoming the first non
Korean to win a World Championship Sara
also became the first player to truly
destabilize that dominance and prove
that you don't need to be Korean to play
Starcraft at the highest level we might
finally have the chosen one the prophecy
may come true players from outside Korea
are rarely seen as a major threat in
StarCraft and Sara is about as
non-korean as it gets
Sara isn't from a metropolis with a
panful less gamers in Seoul he's from a
farming village in rural Finland
I'm from bar 9 in Finland we have five
dozen people hurt so guess you could
call it the village now it's important
to understand that the twenty-year-old
Zerg player had been playing Starcraft
competitively since 2012 he'd also been
putting up middling results until his
meteoric rise in 2018 he only made a WCS
finals once which was his only top four
appearance up until last year Sarah had
been overshadowed by other foreign hooks
like liebe Scarlett special or a laser
who'd help close the gap between Korean
and non-korean play but in 2018
Sarah dwarfed any of his predecessors
achievements we've seen his
determination build himself up this took
years of dedication and practice this
didn't happen overnight we've seen him
grinding those tournaments since he was
about 14 years old
here he is many years later and he is
the undisputed best player in the world
winning is one thing but winning the way
that's several did I think throughout
this weekend is this unbelievable we
often see people win it through it amid
but like I may be in death face in the
game he's still vulnerable he looks like
such a complete player he truly looks
like he's comfortable in every face of
the game in all matchups with all unit
compositions sales incredible season
began in a light sing at the first
circuit event for the Starcraft 2 world
Championship Series where he defeated
Showtime to win his first WCS title
thanks to this short time celebrate
posted with a ton of unit assistant all
the units coming in from the south side
the Lark is separating a couple these
arrow it's going to be the first ever
still easiest champion for the 2018
season will play
from then on Sarah became an unstoppable
force solidifying himself as the best
non-korean player in the world but
sterols does not today is going to kite
backwards the zealots are gone the
archons are gone we've got a champion
he closes in surrounds him and takes
them out GG Cheryl
he is your W CF Valencia champion
[Music]
this is an unreliable player in the
non-koreans Starcraft 2 scene one of the
best real gamers in the urate then the
time came for the Finnish phenom true
test GSL vs. the world an event that hit
the very best of the WCS against the
biggest names in Korean Starcraft cero
kicked off the playoff stage by toppling
two of South Korea's biggest names dark
and four-time GSL winner innovation the
demos are getting lower this is going to
be problematic here for innovation
acquaints come down as well the Queen
see in the transfusions and if the fun
toes open those legs are gonna get on
that tank and it's gonna be lights out
for innovation okay Jay
cero 1 2 3 0 WCS the world fights back
then he faced off against stats
South Korea's highest rated Protoss in
one of the seasons and most fiercely
fought finals this is what it all comes
down to three capture map number seven
spread the word will Sarah take down all
the top koreans to be the best player in
the world 20 years of domination from
Korea in StarCraft good and here we have
never had a non-korean in the eight
years of GSL in a finals like this Sarah
could upset the world to my symbols on
the Left taping a lot of damages
spending so much time by growing on the
rain but if he can kill these roaches he
could be in a good spot groves now stir
in the fall as well the second immoral
gets picked off you can see the
corrosive vials hitting those shallots
he's
got these immortals over here the Nexus
is very low the Oracle trying to come in
here nails out another bottle goes down
JJ is done sale is your DSL versus the
world champion a long road a hard road
possibly the hardest road this is your
champion real by the time Sarah went on
to win his fourth WCS circuit event in
Montreal becoming the only player to win
all four events in a single season he
had already turned the Starcraft 2 world
upside down for the first time in the
history of Starcraft it became at the
very least arguable that the best player
in the world was a non-korean Saros
winning this there's a there's a thing
about destiny momentum I just believe it
I've seen this kind of [ __ ] before I my
heart will shatter if this is not true
but I've never seen these kind of stars
align where we actually have a foreigner
they can go into a tournament like
Blizzcon which has a weird special extra
something to it like koreans turn it on
to die xi there as well and it's if sara
could go in and do it there that is one
of the most pronounced statements in the
history of online gaming but in order
for sara supremacy to become
indisputable he had one last thing to do
something that no non Korean player had
ever done before
win blitz car
[Music]
[Music]
since 2005 the Starcraft World
Championship held at Blizzcon has
crowned a Korean champion every single
year winning the tournament would mean
overthrowing eSports oldest monarchy
achieving the impossible and redefining
the scenes expectations for WCS players
Sarah entered the tournament as the
greatest hope that non Korean Starcraft
fans had ever seen
now granted the last officia stop was
his most mortal if you will which are
kind of the most maps yeah looked
beatable all in DBZ mind you he's still
going to this Blizzcon as v-dog the guy
that has a chance to step into a
Blizzcon and actually win it as a
foreigner which we have never ever had
we've had good foreigners and we've been
like they can go far right but nobody
with any kind of conscience has said
they could win it this is the first time
after going undefeated in the group
stage ceral swept dark in the
quarterfinals before moving on to topple
Rome the defending Blizzcon champion in
Sami sera landed some impressive miles
gets his own mark is buried in the
ground
he does have detection does he have
enough I think he might just barely
clear up the last of the lockers and
saral manages Dagon he loses his luck a
counter-attack of the other side of the
map though food play is trading punches
like crazy then will be the last fight
rogue is out cero where Jake gets itself
a bread final appearance for the first
time here it was gone the sterile versus
stats cheetahs Elvis the world grand
final will be rematch spirit alive
to see who is the greatest player of
2018 Pharaoh became the first-ever non
Korean player to play in a Blizzcon
final and he was preparing himself for
rematch against stats the difference was
that this time there was a World
Championship on the line can the shield
of fire take home that WCS trophy or
will we witness Starcraft history and
see a non-korean become the undisputed
best player in the world get ready
it is Stas and so this is truly the
first time we may have the best player
in the world as a non-korean you're
absolutely right artosis Serra looking
so scary many are saying he is the
favorite here but it's hard to stay on
top for that long if ceral can't make it
here it may never be done artosis the
best-of-seven theories was close but
sarah went into game fix up three to two
on match points after steadily out
playing his opponent the time had
finally come for Sarah to put the final
nail in his rivals coffin okay he's
going for it
he's unloading those carriers in here
and taking them out and it seems like
status is decided he's to take his fight
elsewhere oh my god beautiful execution
here from sarah picking up so many
archons as well as some of these capital
ships and now it's stats giving up bases
carrying the weight of the non-korean
world on his shoulders
Pharaoh poked and prodded at his
opponent until status are me and a
nearly two decade old dynasty came
crashing down Cyril go for a big fight
he's acting beautiful snipe on the
mothership it's gonna be a lot easier
for so to engage when he decides it's
that moment these carriers have such
damn jump but you can really see but
look at that every time an abduct goes
off
their carrier to morph all the brood
Lords starting to get picked off here as
well though he comes in once more he
could basically would shot these
carriers and I don't if they're gentle
ocean Empress death he's gonna commit
Sheryl overwhelming the airplane stats
and
whether you're a fan of Starcraft 2 in
particular or eSports in general it's
hard not to get excited about Sarah with
2019 on the horizon and the entire WCS
under his belt sarah has just one last
accolade a left to take a GSL title a
non-korean player has never won the GSL
but sarah has already made history one
this goes beyond you becoming the best
of the best your legacy goes beyond
Starcraft you it goes to all of
Starcraft history in the last 20 years
we have never seen a non-korean dominate
in the fashion that you have and become
the best of the best like you have right
now I'm at the top so I feel like I
really want to keep this going and I'm
trying my hardest to keep it going
trying to make make the most of it all
the time
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]